The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JEREMY KEPNER: Thank
you all for coming.
I'm glad to see
that our attendance
after the first lecture has
not dropped dramatically--
a little bit.
That's to be expected.
But so far I haven't managed
to scare you all off.
So this is the second lecture
of the signal processing
on database of course.
The format of the lecture will
be the same as the last one.
We'll have some slide
material that will cover
the first half of the course.
And then we'll
take a short break.
And then there'll be some
example demo programs.
And so with that,
we'll get into it.
And all this material is
available in your LLGrid
accounts.
In the Tools directory you
get a directory like this.
And the documents and the
slides are right here.
So we'll go to lecture 01.
For those of you
who weren't there
or to recap for those who will
be viewing this on the web
later, the title of the
course is Signal Processing
on Databases-- two terms that
we often don't see together.
The signal processing
element is really
alluding to detection theory,
and the deeper linear algebra
basis of detection theory.
The databases is really alluding
to unstructured data, data
that we often represent with
strings and words and sort
of sparse relationships.
And so this course is
really bringing these two
normally quite separate ideas
and bringing them together
in a way because there's
a lot of need to do so.
So again, this is
the first course
ever taught on this topic.
There really isn't a prior
model for how to teach this.
So the approach
that we're taking
is we're going to
have a lot of examples
that show how people
use this technology
and hopefully see that.
And then we'll also have
some theory as well as
a lot of examples.
And so hopefully
through some combination
of those different types of
teaching vehicles, each of you
will be able to find
something that is helpful.
So the outline of
today's lecture
is I'm going to go
through an example
where we analyzed
some citation data.
So citation data is one of
the most common examples used
in the field because it's so
readily available and so easy
to get.
And so there's no issues
associated with it.
So you have lots of academics
analyzing themselves,
which is, of course,
very symmetric, right?
And so there's a lot of
work on citation data.
We are going to be looking
at some citation data here,
but doing it using the
technology, the D4M technology,
that you all have
access to, doing it
in the way that would work
well there, which we think
is more efficient both in
terms of the performance
that you'll get on
your analytics and just
in terms of the total
time it will take you.
Of course, it does require
a certain level of comfort
with linear algebra.
That's sort of the mathematical
foundation of the class.
So we're going to
get right into it.
And I talked about this
in the previous lecture,
these special schemas
that we set up
for processing this kind of data
that allow us to, essentially,
take any kind of data
and sort of pull it
into one basic
architecture that is
a really a good starting
point for analysis.
So here's a very
classic type of data
that you might get in
citation data here.
So in this particular
data set, we
have a universal identifier
for each citation.
So every single
citation is just given
some index in this data set.
And we'll have an author, a doc
ID, and then a reference doc
ID.
So this basically
is the document ID
of the document that's
being referenced
and the one that the
reference is coming from.
That may seem a little opposite.
But that's sort
of what it means.
And you can have
absences of both.
You can have
references where it's
referring to another document
for which they have not
constructed some
kind of document ID.
You can also have
references that
are within a document that
just for some reason or other
doesn't have a
document ID as well.
So I think the important
thing to understand here
is that this kind of
incompleteness on a data set,
which might be as clean a
data set as you would expect,
which is the scientific
citation data
set, this kind of
incompleteness is very normal.
You never get data sets that
are even remotely perfect.
To get good data sets that
feel even like about 80% solid,
you're doing very well.
And it's very,
very common to have
data sets that are
incomplete, that have
mistakes, null values,
mislabeled fields, et cetera,
et cetera.
It is just a natural
part of the process.
I think even though more
and more of these sets
are created by
machines and you're
hoping that would eliminate
some of those issues,
well, the machines
have the same problems.
And they can make mistakes
on a much larger scale,
more quickly than humans can.
So incompleteness
definitely exists.
We pull this data
into-- this data
is sort of a standard SQL
or tabular format here,
in which you have records
and columns and then values.
And what we tend
generally do is pull it
into what we call
this exploded schema
where we still use the records.
Those are the row keys.
We create column keys,
which are essentially
the column label and the
column value appended together.
So every single unique value
will have its own column.
And then we sort of
build it out that way.
And this creates this very,
very large, sparse structure.
Once we store the transpose of
that in our database as well,
we get, essentially,
constant-time access
to any string in the database.
So we can now look up
any author very quickly,
any document very quickly,
any record very quickly.
And so it's a very
natural schema
for handling this kind of data.
Typically, we just
hold the value 1
in the actual value
of the database.
We can put other
numbers in there.
But it generally
should be a number
that you would never
want to search on
because in many of the
data sets that we have
or the databases
we're working with,
they can look up a row key or
with this schema, a column key
very quickly.
But to look up a value
requires a complete traversal
of the table, which is, by
definition, very expensive.
So there's definitely
information
you can put in there but just
general information you would
never want to really look up.
In addition for this
particular data set,
we have some fields
that are quite long.
And so we might have the
fully formatted reference,
which in a journal
article can be quite long.
You know if it's got the full
name and the journal volume
and maybe all the authors
and all that stuff, that
can be quite long.
It's very unstructured.
We might have the title.
We might have the abstract.
These are longer blobs of
data that maybe our other data
set essentially is extracted all
the key information from that.
But often, we still
want to have access
to this information as a
complete uninterrupted piece
of data.
So if you actually find a
record, you're like, well,
I'd like to see the abstract
as it was actually formatted
as it was in the journal.
Because a lot of times when
you pull this stuff out and do
keywords, you might lose
punctuation, capitalization,
other types of
things that just make
it generally easier to
read, but don't really
help you with indexing.
So we actually recommend
that that kind of information
be stored in a completely
separate table--
a traditional table, which would
just be some kind of row key
and then the actual reference
with the values there.
You're never going to
search the contents of this.
But this allows you to at
least have access to the data.
So this is sort of a small
addition to our standard schema
where we have the exploded
schema with all the information
that we would ever
want to search on
with this transpose, which
gives us a very fast search.
You may have an
additional table which
just stores the data in
a raw format separately.
You can look it up quickly.
But it won't get in the way
of any of your searches.
The problem can be if
you're doing searches
and you have very large
fields mixed in with very
small fields, it can become
a performance bottleneck
to be handling these
at the exact same time.
Another table that
we used in this data
set, which was to
essentially index
all the words in the title and
the abstract and their Ngrams,
and so the one gram would
just be the individual words
in a title.
If a word appeared
in a title, you
would create a new column
for that word with respect
to that reference.
An Ngram would be word pairs.
A trigram would be all
words that occur together
in threes and on and on and on.
And so often for text analytics,
you want to store all of these.
And essentially, you might
have here an input data
set with various
identifiers-- a title that
consists of a set of
words, an abstract that
consists of set of words.
And then typically
what we would do
is we would say for the
one gram of the title a,
we might format it like this.
And then here we
might hold where
that appeared in the document.
So this allows you
to, essentially,
come back and reconstruct
the original documents.
So that's a perfectly
good example
of something that we don't
tend to need to search on,
which is the exact position
of a word in a document.
We don't tend to really
care that the word was
in the eighth position or the
10th position or whatever.
So we can just create a
list of all of these values.
And that way, if you want
to then later reconstruct
the original text,
you can do that.
Between a column
and its positions,
you have enough
information to do that.
So that's an example of another
type of schema that we admit
and how we handle
this type of data
for doing these
types of searches.
And now it makes it very
easy to say, show me,
if I wanted to look up, please
give me all documents that
had the word d, this
word d, in the abstract,
I would simply go over
here, look up the row key,
get these two columns, and then
I could take those two column
labels and then
look them up here.
And I would get all the Ngrams.
Or I could then
take those row keys
and look them up in any
of the previous tables
and get that information.
So that's kind of
what you can do there.
I'm going over this
kind of quickly.
The examples go through this
in very specific detail.
But this is kind
of just showing you
how we tend to think about
these data sets in a way that's
very flexible.
But showing you
some of the nuances.
It's not just the one table.
It ends up being
two or three tables.
But still, that really covers
what you're looking for.
Again, when you're
processing data like this,
you're always thinking
about a pipeline.
And D4M, the technologies
you talk about
is only one piece
of that pipeline.
We're not saying
that the technologies
we're talking about cover every
single step of that pipeline.
So in this particular
data set that we had,
which I think was 150
gigabyte data set,
step one was getting a
hard disk drive sent to us
and copying it.
It came as a giant XML zip file.
Obviously we had
to uncompress it.
So we had to zip file.
We uncompressed it.
And then from there
we had to write
a parser of the
XML that then spat
that out into just
a series of triples
that then could be inserted into
our database the way we want.
Well, D4M forum is very
good for developing
how you're going to want to
parse those triples initially.
If you're going to do a
high volume parsing of data,
I would really recommend
using a low-level language
like C. Generally C is an
outstanding language for doing
this very repetitive,
monotonous parsing
and has excellent support
for things like XML
and other types of things.
And it will run as
fast as you can.
Yeah, you end up writing
more code to do that.
But it tends to be kind of
a do once type of thing.
You actually do it more than
once, usually, to get it right.
But it's nice when, I think,
our parser that we wrote in C++
could take this several
hundred gigabytes of XML data
and convert it in
triples in under an hour.
And so that's a nice thing.
And other environments,
if you try
and to do this in, say, Python
or other types of things
or even in D4M at
high volume, it's
going to take a lot longer.
So the right tool
for the job-- it
will take you more
lines of code to do it.
But we have found that it's
usually a worthwhile investment
because it can take a long time.
Once we have the triples,
typically what we then do
is read them into D4M and
construct dissociative arrays
out of them.
Talked a little bit about
associative arrays last time.
I'll get to that again.
But these are essentially
a MATLAB data structure.
And then we generally
save them to files.
We always recommend
right before you
do an insert into
a database, even
when you write
performance parsers
or if you're not
writing, the parsing
can be a significant activity.
And if you write the data out
in some sort of efficient file
format right before you insert
it, if you ever need to go back
and re insert the data, it's now
a very, very fast thing to do.
You'll often have databases
especially during development,
they can get corrupted.
You try and recover them
but they don't recover.
And again, just knowing that
you have the parsed files laying
around someplace and you
can just process them
whenever you want is a
very useful technique
and usually is not such a large
expense from a data perspective
and can allow you
essentially reinsert
the data at the full rate the
database can handle, as opposed
to having you redo your
parsing, which sometimes
can take 10 times as long.
We've definitely
seen many folks who
do full parsing, text parsing
in Java or in Python that often
is 10 times slower
than the actual insert
part of the database.
So it's nice to be able
to checkpoint that data.
And then from there we
read the files in and then
insert them into our three
two database pairs-- the keys
and the transpose, the
Ngrams and the transpose,
and then the actual
raw text itself.
I should also say, keeping
these associative arrays around
as files is also very useful.
Because the database, as
we talked about before,
is very good if you have
a large volume of data
and you want to look up a
small piece of it quickly.
If you want to re-traverse
the entire data set,
do some kind of analysis
on the entire data set,
that's going to take
about the same time
as it took to insert the data.
So you're going to be having
to pull all the data out
if you're going to be
wanting to analyze all of it.
There's no sort of magic there.
So the database is very useful
for looking up small pieces.
But if you want to traverse
the whole thing, in which case
having those files around
is a very convenient thing.
If you're like, I'm going
to traverse all the data,
I might as well just begin with
the files and traverse them.
And that's very easy.
The file system will read it in
much faster than the database.
The bandwidth of
the file systems
are much higher than databases.
And it's also very easy to
handle in a parallel way.
You just send different
processes, parse--
in reading in different files.
So if you're going to be
doing something that traverses
an entire set of data, we
really recommend that you
might do that in files.
And in fact, we
even see folks its
like, well, I might have a
query that requires 3% or 4%
of the data.
Well then we would
recommend, oftentimes,
if you know you're going to be
working on that same data set
over and over again, querying
it out of the database,
saving to a set
of files, and then
just working with those
files over and over again.
Now you never have to deal with
the latencies or other issues
associated with the database.
You've completely isolated
yourself from that.
So databases are great.
You need to use them
for the right thing.
But the file system
is also great.
And often in the kind
of work that we do,
that algorithm
development people do,
testing and developing
on the files
is often better than
using the database
as your fine-grain rudimentary
access type of thing.
So we covered that.
So this particular data
set had 42 million records.
And just to kind of
show you how long it
took using the pipeline, we
uncompressed the XML file
in one hour.
So that's just running gzip.
Our parser, that converted
the XML binary structure
into triples, this was
written in C#, was two hours.
So that's very, very nice.
As we debug the parser, we
could rewrite it and not
have to worry about,
oh my goodness, this
is going to be days and days.
The constructing of the
D4M associative arrays
from the triples
took about a day.
That just kind of
just shows you there.
And then inserting the
triples into Accumulo,
this was a single node database.
Not a powerful computer, it was
a dual core circa 2006 Server.
But we have sustained
an insert rate
of about 10,000 to 100,000
entries per second, which
is extremely good for this
particular database, which
was Accumulo.
So inserting the keys
took about two days.
Inserting the text
took about one day.
Inserting the Ngrams
took about 10 days
in this particular data set.
We ended up not using
the Ngrams very much
in this particular data
set, mostly the keys.
And so there you go.
That gives you an idea.
If the database itself
is running in parallel,
you can increase those
insert rates significantly.
But these are the basic
single node insert performance
that we tend to see.
Yes, question over here.
AUDIENCE: Silly question.
Is Accumulo a type
of a database?
JEREMY KEPNER: Ah yes.
So I talked about that a
little bit in the first class.
So Accumulo is a type of
database called a triple store
or sometimes called
a NoSQL database.
It's a new class
of database that's
based on the
architecture published
in the Google
Bigtable paper, which
is about five or six years old.
There's a number of
databases that have been
built with this technology.
It sits on top of a file system
infrastructure called Hadoop.
And it's a very, very
high performance database
for what it does.
And that's the database
that we use here.
And it's open source, a
part of the Apache project.
You can download it.
And at the end of
the class, we'll
actually be doing examples
working with databases.
We are developing an
infrastructure, part of LLGrid,
to host these databases
so that you don't really
have to kind of mess around
with the details of them.
And our hope is to have
that infrastructure
ready by the last two classes
so that you guys can actually
try it out, so.
So the next thing
we want to do here
is after we've built
these databases,
I want to show you how
we construct graphs
from this exploded schema.
Formally, this exploded
schema is what you
would call an incidence matrix.
So in graph theory,
graphs generally
can be represented as two
different types of matrix--
an adjacency matrix, which
is a matrix where each row
and column is a vertex.
And then if there is an
edge between two vertices,
there'll be a value
associated with that.
Generally very sparse
in the types of data
sets that we work with.
That is great for covering
certain types of graphs.
It handles directed
graphs very well.
It does not handle graphs
with multiple edges very well.
It does not handle
graphs with hyper-edges.
These are edges that
connect multiple vertices
at the same time.
And the data that
we have here is very
much in that latter category.
A citation, essentially,
is a hyper-edge.
Or basically one of these
things it connects a document
with sets of people,
with sets of titles,
with sets of all
different types of things.
So it's a very, very
rich edge that's
connecting a lot of vertices.
And so a traditional
adjacency matrix
doesn't really capture it.
So that's why we store the data
as an incidence matrix, which
is essentially one
row for each edge.
And then the columns
are vertices.
And then you basically
have information
that shows which vertices
are connected by that edge.
So that's how we store the
data in a lossless fashion.
And we have a mechanism for
storing it and indexing it
fairly efficiently.
That said, the types of
analyses we want to do,
tend to very quickly get
us to adjacency matrices.
For those of you who are
familiar with radar-- and this
is probably the only place where
I could say that-- I almost
think of one as kind
of the voltage domain
and the other the power domain.
You do lose information when
you go to the power domain.
But often, to make
progress on your analytics,
you have to do that.
And so the adjacency matrix
is a formal projection
of the incidence matrix.
You essentially, by multiplying
the incidence matrix by itself
or squaring it, can get
the adjacency matrix.
So let's look at that.
So here's an adjacency
matrix of this data
that shows the source document
and the cited document.
And so this just shows
what we see in this data--
--cornor up here.
If you see my mouse
going up here, scream.
So we'll stay in the safe area.
So This is the source document.
And this is the cited document.
This is a significant
subset of this data set.
I think it's only 1,000 records.
It's sort of a random sample.
If I showed you
the real, full data
set, obviously that
it just be solid blue.
The source document
ID is decreasing.
And basically, newer
documents are at the bottom,
older documents at the top.
I assume everyone
can know why we have
the sharp-edged boundary here.
AUDIENCE: Can you
cite future documents?
JEREMY KEPNER: You can't
cite future documents, right?
This is the Einstein event
cone of this data set, right?
You can't cite documents
into the future.
So that's why we have
that boundary there.
And you could
almost see it here.
You see-- and I don't
think that's just
an optical illusion-- you
see how it's denser here
and sparser here, which
just shows as documents
get published over time,
they get cited less and less
going into the future.
I think one statistic is that if
you eliminated self-citations,
most published journal
articles are never cited.
So thank God for self-citation.
This shows the degree
distribution of this data.
We'll get into this in
great much greater detail.
But this just shows here on this
small subset of data, basically
for each document we count
how many times it was cited.
So these are documents
that are cited more.
And then we count
how many documents
have that number of citations.
10 to the 0 is basically
documents that are cited once.
And there shows the
number of documents
in this set here, which
was 20,000, 30,000, 40,000
that have one citation.
And then going on down here to
the one that is cited the most.
This is what is called a
power law distribution.
Basically it just says most
things are not cited very often
and some things are
cited a long time.
You see those are
on a approximately
linear negative slope
in a log-log plot.
This is something that
we see all the time,
I should say, in what we
call sub-sampled data where
essentially the
space of citations
has not been fully sampled.
If people stopped publishing
and we created new documents
and all citations only were of
older things, then over time
you would probably
see this thing
begin to take on a bit more
of a bell-shaped curve, OK?
But as long as you're
an expanding world,
then you will get this
type of power law.
And a great many
of the data sets
that we tend to work with
fall in this category.
And, in fact, if
you work with data
that is a byproduct of
artificial human-induced
phenomena, this is
what you should expect.
And if you don't see
it, then you kind of
want to question
what's going on there.
There's usually
something going on there.
So those are some
overall statistics.
Those are two things that
we-- the adjacency matrix
and the redistribution of two
things that we often look at.
I'm going to move things
forward here and talk
about the different
types of adjacency matrix
we might construct from
the incidence matrix.
So in general, the
adjacency matrix
is often denoted
by the letter A.
And incident matrices, you
think we might use the letter I.
But I has obviously been
taken in matrix theory.
So we tend to use the letter
E for the edge matrix.
So I used E as the associative
array representation
of my edge matrix here.
And if I want to find the
author-author correlation
matrix, I just basically can do
E starts with author transpose
times E starts with author.
So basically the
starts with author
is the part of the
incidence matrix
that has just the authors.
I now have an associative
array of just authors.
And then I square
it with itself.
And you get, obviously, a
square symmetric matrix that
is dense along that diagonal
because every single document,
the author appears with itself.
And then this just
shows you which authors
appear with which other author.
So if two authors appear on
the same article together,
they would get a dot.
And so there's a
very classic type
of graph, the co-author graph.
It's well studied, has
a variety of phenomena
associated with it.
And here, it's
constructed very simply
from this
matrix-matrix multiply.
I'm going to call
this the inner square.
So we actually have a short
cut for this in D4M called
[INAUDIBLE].
So [INAUDIBLE] means the
matrix transposed times
itself, which sort of has
an inner product feel to it.
No one has their name
associated with this product.
Seems like someone missed
an opportunity there.
All of the special matrices
are named after Germans.
And so some German missed
an opportunity there back
in the days.
Maybe we can call it the
Inner Kepner product.
That would sufficiently
expire it-- obscure it
like the Hadamard product,
which I always have to look up.
And here is the outer product.
So this shows you the
distribution of the documents
that share common authors.
So it's the same.
What I'm trying to show you
is these adjacency matrices
are formally projections
of the incidence
matrix onto a subspace.
And whether you do
the inner squaring
or the outer squaring
product, those
both have valuable information.
One of them showed
us which authors
have published together.
The other one shows us which
documents have common authors.
Both very legitimate
pieces to analyze.
And in each case, we've
lost some information
by constructing it.
But probably out
of necessity, we
have to do this to make
progress on the analysis
that we're doing.
And continuing, we can
look at the institutions.
So here's the inner
institution squaring product.
And so this shows you
which institutions
are on the same paper.
And then likewise, this
shows us which documents
share the same institution.
Same thing with keywords,
which pairs of keywords
occur in the same document,
which document share
the same keywords, et
cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
Typically, when we do
this matrix multiply,
if we have the
value be a 1, then
actually that the value of
the result will be the count.
So this would show
you how many keywords
are shared by the document.
Or in the previous one, how
many times a pair of keywords
appear in the same
document together.
Again, valuable information
for constructing analytics.
And so these inner and
outer Kepner products
or whatever you
want to call them,
are very useful in that regard.
So now we're going to take
a little bit of a turn here.
This is really going to lead
you up into the examples.
So we're going to get back in
to this point I made and kind
of revisit it again, which
is the issues associated
with adjacency matrix,
hypergraphs, multi-edge graphs,
and those types of things.
I think I've already
talked about this.
Just to remind people, here's
a graph, a directed graph.
We've numbered all the vertices.
This is the adjacency
matrix of that graph.
So basically two
vertices have an edge.
They get a dot.
The fundamental
operation of graph theory
is what we call
breadth-first search.
So you start at a vertex and
then go to its neighbors,
following the edges.
The fundamental operation
of linear algebra
is vector matrix multiply.
So if I construct a vector with
a value in a particular vertex
and I do the matrix
multiply, I find the edges
and I result in the neighbors.
And so you have
this formal duality
between the fundamental
operation of graph theory
here, which is breadth-first
search and a linear algebra.
And so this is philosophically
how we will think about that.
And I think we've already
shown a little bit of that when
we talk about these projections
from incidence matrices
to adjacency matrices.
And again, to get
into that a little bit
further and bring that point
home, the traditional graph
theory that we are taught
in graph theory courses
tends to focus on what we call
undirected, unweighted graphs.
So these are graphs
with vertices.
And you just say whether there's
a connection between vertices.
And you may not
have any information
about if there's multiple
connections between vertices.
And you certainly
can't do hyper-edges.
And this gives you this
very black and white picture
of the world here, which is not
really what the world really
looks like.
And in fact, there's a painting
courtesy of a friend of mine
who is an artist who does
this type of painting.
I tend to like it.
And this is the same painting
of what I showed before,
but what it really looks like.
And what you see is that this
is really more representative
of the true world.
Just drawing some straight edge
lines with colors on a canvas
we already have gone
well beyond what
we could easily represent with
undirected, unweighted graphs.
First of all, our edges
in this case have color.
We have five distinct
colors, which
is information that
would not be captured
in the traditional
unweighted, undirected graph
representation.
We have 20 distinct
vertices here.
So I've labeled every
intersection or ending
of a line as a vertex.
So we have five colors
and 20 distinct vertices.
We have 12 things
that we really should
consider to be multi-edges, OK?
These are essentially
multiple edges
that connect the same vertices.
And I've labeled them
by their color here.
We have 19 hyper-edges.
These are edges
that fundamentally
connect more than one vertex.
So if we look at
this example here,
P3 connects this vertex,
this vertex, this vertex,
and this vertex with one edge.
We could, of course,
topologically say, well, this
is the same as just having
an edge from here to here
or here to here to here.
But that's not what's
really going on.
We are throwing away information
if we decompose that.
Finally, we often have a
concept of edge ordering.
The order that the
line is drawn here,
you can infer it just from
the layering of the lines
that certain edges
occur before others.
And ordering is
also very important.
And anyone want to guess what
color was the first color
of this painting?
When the artist started,
they painted one color first.
Anyone want to guess
what that color was?
AUDIENCE: Red.
JEREMY KEPNER: What?
AUDIENCE: Brown?
JEREMY KEPNER: It was an orange.
It was orange.
And I would have never
have guessed that
except by talking to the artist,
which I found interesting.
And when she was telling
me how she did it,
it was so counterintuitive
to the perception
of the work, which I think
is very, very interesting.
So if you were to represent
this in a standard graph,
you would create
53 standard edges.
You would say this
hyper-edge here,
we would break up into
three separate edges.
This hyper-edge you would break
up into two separate edges
et cetera, et cetera.
So you have 53 standard edges.
So one of the basic
observations is
that the standard edge
representation, the fragments,
or hyper-edges, a lot
of information is lost.
The digraph representation
compresses the multi-edges.
And a lot of
information is lost.
The matrix representation
drops the edge labels.
And a lot of
information is lost.
And the standard
graph representation
drops the edge order.
And again, more
information loss.
So we really need something
better than the traditional way
to do that.
And so the solution
to this problem
is to use the incidence
matrix formulation
where we assign
every single edge
a label, a color, an order
that it was laid down.
And then for every
single vertex we
can-- so this edge B1 is blue.
It's in the second order group.
And its connects
these three vertices.
And you see various
structures here appearing
from the different
types of things.
So this is how we would
represent this data
as an incidence
matrix in a way that
preserves all the information.
And so that's really kind of the
power of the incidence matrix
approach to this.
All right.
So that actually brings us
to the end of the first-- oh,
so we have a question here.
AUDIENCE: So this
is great, and I've
worked with [INAUDIBLE] before.
But what kind of analysis
can you actually do on that?
JEREMY KEPNER: So the
analysis you typically
do is you take projections
into adjacency matrices.
Yep.
So this way, you're
preserving the ability
to do all those
projections, you know?
And it's not to say
sometimes to make progress
if your data sets
are large, you're
just forced to just make some
projections to get started.
Theoretically, one could argue
that the right way to proceed
is you have the
incidence matrix.
You derive the
analytics you want.
Maybe you use
adjacency matrices as
an analytic intermediate step.
But then once you've
figured out the analysis,
you then go back and make sure
that the analytic runs just
on the raw instance
matrix itself
and save yourself the time
of actually constructing
the adjacency matrix.
Sometimes this
space is so large,
though, it can be difficult for
us to get our mind around it.
And sometimes it
can be useful just
like you know what,
I really think
that these projections are
going to be useful ones to get
started.
Rather than trying to just
get lost in this forest,
sometimes it's better
to be like I'm just
going to start by projecting.
I'm going to create a few
of these adjacency matrices
to get started, make
progress, do my analytics,
and then figure out if I
need to fix it from there.
Because working in
this space directly
can be a little bit tricky.
Every single analysis--
it's like working
in the voltage domain.
You're constantly having to
keep extra theoretical machinery
around.
And sometimes to make progress,
you're better off just
going to the power
domain, making progress,
and maybe discover
later if you can fix it
up doing other types of things.
Are there other
questions before we
come to the end of this
part of the lecture?
Great.
OK, thank you.
So we'll take a
short break here.
And then we'll
proceed to the demo.
There is a sign-up sheet here.
If you haven't signed
up, please write it down.
Apparently this is extremely
important for the accounting
purposes of the laboratory.
So I would encourage
you to do that.
So we'll start up again
in about five minutes.